so the contradiction that I want to talk
about in the Quran today is this this
concept
that there is the concept of bearing
burdens in the Quran it's very
conflicting you have quite a few verses
that say that no bearer of burdens can
bear the burdens of another while you
have other verses that say the opposite
that say that there are uh bearer of
burdens that will bear their own burdens
and also bear the burdens of others
um so this is the contradictions that
we're going in one verse is chapter 35
verse 18. it says no bearer of burdens
can bear the burdens of another
and then another verse 29 verse 13 and
you have 16 25 that says that bearer of
burdens will bear their own burdens and
the burdens of others that they've
misled
so which is it can they bear the burdens
of others or can they not
all right are you done with that
yes sir Okay so
if you look in 29 13 which uh which he
brings up
and you look back one verse that's one
of the problems that we get with
Christians when they look at the Quran
uh they they forget that it's the same
thing as the Bible in places you have to
look at the context
so in 2912 it specifically said those
who disbelieved said to those who
believed if you follow our way we will
be responsible for your sins
uh not true they cannot bear any of
their sins they are liars in fact they
will carry their own sins in addition to
the loads of other people's sins which
they
were responsible for or responsible
most certainly they will be asked on the
day of Resurrection about their false
claims
so it is
uh clear here that in the context what
they're talking about they're talking to
those who disbelieved
that said to those who believed if you
follow our way we will be responsible
for your sins which they can't be so
they lied to them and said we're going
to be responsible for those sins the
sins they will be responsible for are
their own the disbelievers will be
responsible for their own and for the
fact that they
um
that they LED others astray
so uh when it says here this and if you
look at 1625 you have the exact same
issue it's a context issue so if we go
to let me switch to
1625 real quick and I'll read that
because this is a very similar verse to
the other one now another thing with
chapter 29 is the word for loads and and
the word in 35 18 are two different even
the uh the the word that it comes from
is different so actually the smartest
thing would go to the 1625 because it
uses the same base word so if we look at
1625 it says they will be held
responsible for their sins on the day of
Resurrection all of them in addition to
the Sins Of Those whom they misled by
their ignorance what a miserable load so
to me it's very clear that what it's
showing is is that you're going to be
responsible for your own sins
and if you lead somebody astray you're
going to be responsible for leading
somebody astray but you do not take from
their sins they are still responsible
for their own load all right so let's
read these together which one are you
going to first uh 35 18. all right so it
says and no if you can give me a minute
my my system's slow give me just a
minute so I can read it with you
and what what translation are you using
um picked off
oh okay all right so it says no burden
so can bear another's burden correct
yeah this says no soul can carry the
sins of another yeah so no burdened so
specifically
no burden Soul can bear the burdens of
another
now in the other verse that we read
in 1625 and 29 13 because you said they
they're both the same thing which I
agree so we could just read one of them
um and 35 uh I'm sorry 1625 it says that
they will bear their own burdens
on the day of resurrection and some of
the burdens of Those whom they've misled
without knowledge right
so
are they bearing their own burdens and
the burdens of others
no just like it says right here starting
and we'll start with 35 18. it says no
soul can carry this into another Soul so
we know that
if a soul that is loaded with sins
implores another to Bear part of its
load no other Soul can carry any part of
it
even if they were related
to uh even if they were related so even
if they were brother and sister or what
have you the the only people
uh to heed your warnings are those
reverence that are Lord and it goes on
from there I mean if there's something
down there that's important to you the
main thing is is it's clear nobody can
take the burden of somebody else's uh
sins right except for
here's the issue that you got what do
you see except for I'll tell you why
because you're not taking their burdens
that's what it says though no it doesn't
actually what it says is is that you're
going to be responsible let's go to 16
25.
for the sin of leading them astray
that's not what it says all right I'm
about to read it for you and then you'll
see says they will be held responsible
for their sins on the day of
Resurrection all of them
in addition to the sins of All Those
whom they misled by their ignorance okay
what a miserable note so in other words
if you and I go in and rob a store and I
talked you into doing it you're still
going to Bear the sin of robbing the
store but I'm also going to get I'm
gonna have the uh the sin of uh leading
you to rob that store it doesn't say
that it says here
that they may bear their burdens
unmonished undiminished on the day of
Resurrection with some of the burdens of
Those whom they've misled without
knowledge
so according to this verse
they're bearing their own burdens and
some of the burdens of those they misled
some of those burdens are going to be
put on on them since they caused them to
go astray
correct
now that's uh whatever whatever one
you're reading is uh
is number one is not one that I use
anyone that's literally what it says
really so you know Arabic is what you're
saying well wait oh should we go to the
Arabic let's go to the Arabic you know
Arabic
I love to go to the Corpus no do you
know Eric I don't have to we could do
word study I don't have to
no we're not if you don't know Arabic
then it's not I rely on the scholars
that do know Arabic Arabic that's
beautiful right well no because is that
how you look at Greek too I rely on the
scholars with no Greek yeah you're an
idiot so it says that that they may bear
that they may bear their own burdens
I.E sins
in full on the day of resurrection and
some of the burdens of Those whom they
misguide without knowledge so can you
bear the burdens of others or not just
like I said I just explained it to you I
know you can't figure it out I get that
but what it says is is
yeah no actually
are you done yet go yeah go ahead I'm
listening bro I'm having a good time no
no I am too Resurrection it says that uh
specifically that they will share the
burdens
of Those whom they misguide without
knowledge so in other words you're gonna
have the burdens of the people you
misguided okay so can you according to
35 18 can you share the burdens of those
you've misguided or not no it
specifically said you cannot okay so
there's the contradiction 35 no actually
it's not a contradiction no
give me the debate
debate you literally just said no it
doesn't you it says you cannot thank you
according to 35 18 no one can bear the
burdens you can't share No burdens with
nobody no situation at all it literally
just blinkets the statement you cannot
bear the burdens of another while 1625
and 2913 gives you a little exception
that you can bear the burdens of those
you misled I don't care how you
absolutely wrong it's still a
contradiction no it isn't
I just explained it now of course you
did you didn't say anything about uh
what I brought up if I cause you to do
something you're still gonna bear the
burden of doing it I bear the burden of
doing it and for late because it says
specifically right there if you read it
all right yeah show show me where does
it say I've already showed you read it
again and think about it
so I'm looking at it right here let's
see here let me make sure
I got both of them up at the same time
all right 16 25.
they oh that they may bear their burdens
undiminished on the day of Resurrection
with some of the burdens of Those whom
they've misled without knowledge ah evil
is that which they bear I don't see what
you said let's go to 2913. but but they
barely will bear their own burdens and
other burdens besides their own yeah
there you have to go back to 12. excuse
me excuse me
and they will barely be questioned on
the day of Resurrection concerning that
which they invented you said it's in
verse 12. yeah all right let's you got
to read the context I mean I know you
don't know what context means no no
let's let's do this let's let's read
verse 12 then
hold on let me let me add verse 12 in
here let's see if it if it helps our
friend Charlie
who who the did you just call me
Charlie I'm not your buddy that's okay
you are my buddy no yeah I love you
you'll respect or I'll call you Avery
why because you're isn't that your name
bro you're a punk you're a punk that's
your name
you want to get stupid with me you
already got stupid I can't even get any
stupid in that yeah I don't think we
can't get in yeah we'll see what happens
when I meet you okay I'm in Balboa Park
12 to uh 6 P.M every Sunday
all right so it says
those verse 12 the one that you wanted
us to read
those who disbelieve say unto those who
believe
follow our way and we verily will bear
your sins they cannot bear
except of their own sins they barely are
liars
so it just said in verse 12. watch this
ladies and gentlemen verse 12 says that
disbelievers say to Believers hey we can
don't worry follow our way and and we
can bear your sins we'll bear your sins
and then it correct something no they
cannot bear their sins except their own
but then verse 13 contradicts that and
says but verily they will bear their own
sins and others besides their own and
they will barely be questioned on the
day of Resurrection concerning that
which they invented man this this is
over man this is over 12 literally
contradicts 13. thank you for showing
that to me
[Music]
foreign